our juice
and we know who you are yes we know
who protects the cow
[Music]
you never told me you had the voice of
an Angel
[Applause]
that was the talented beautiful Rita Ora
lending her most sensual Supple gorgeous
belt out loud voice to the new Netflix
Show Kung Fu Panda the dragon knight now
you play a bear named wandering blade is
it true that you made a few little
additions to her look yeah I got her a
little blonde braid because I'm blonde I
gave her some lashes it's chubby she's
the chicest bear I've ever seen she's
giving me looks yes she I I just love
her I love her it's funny because I
actually took a little
um trip down memory lane for you and me
and our different hairstyles because I
noticed that you did
um give her this beautiful blonde braid
and stunning lashes and so I got some
pictures of us because you're a hair
icon and I just look at you
I have to say I've done a lot of looks
that's so good I just I just feel so
like liberated that I can just change my
look whenever I want and I think growing
up my parents were so supportive of me
just kind of like expressing myself and
yeah that really I I realize that I'm
really lucky that I had those parents
and so I just have never stopped I just
like because I have naturally like
really curly hair so I like to like cut
it up and like color it in and I have a
few more uh well actually Drew we have
some for you because you're a hair icon
too hello yeah yeah so I just like to
change it up oh yeah
the 90s the 90s the 90s are my favorite
but you did this one um movie and you
played Ivy and she has like curly hair
yes like yes and that was my natural
hair but that was I I have naturally
curly hair that was my inspiration
because I never knew how to control
curly hair this hair today
all right I'm Gonna Leave it look at
this picture what's going on oh look at
how stunning you look I love that that
was
literally we just made those Twirly
Whirly things they look like chocolate
bars and we just put them and clip them
into our hair and I have no idea how
they stayed on my my hairdresser
backstage literally we just made them on
the day I love it I love the bows too
okay yeah we have another one of you
take a look at this oh yeah
strawberry blonde I love a redhead I
love red hair this one's one of my
favorites of yours too Rita oh I love
that color play with the pink and the
yellow and the red I want to have fun I
love colors I mean I've been a big fan
of bright colors for ages so yeah I've
done blue green orange is there a color
you haven't done you're gonna do I think
like brown like dark brown I've never
done oh that's my natural real natural I
love that a risk for you is dark brown
right I know that's true I mean I've
done blue and yellow yeah but yeah maybe
a dark I could do that maybe at some
point okay yeah that's a pretty good
idea well the eyebrow okay that one I
did like a fiery red
I brought in
um does anyone remember Tawny kitane and
she was in the white snake videos that
was my I always bring a mood board
picture in and then Rita I love this one
um also I mean look how oh how beautiful
you look at that um this was actually a
really weird time because my hair was at
such a weird length I didn't know what
to do with it so that's why I just did a
wet look and added on some like blonde
bits at the end we have one last look of
one of Drew's hair look at this one I
remember that
what do they say the bigger the hair the
closer to God
well you are a god-ass Rita Ora I am so
excited that we got to finally meet in
person
[Applause]
well Rita Ora season two of Kung Fu
Panda the dragon knight is streaming
next uh streaming now on Netflix and
Rita's new single you only love me is
out now so go and dance to it if you're
not dancing already
[Music]
foreign